cool okay well we're going to take it
kind of slow uh the reason that we're
you know last time was scheduled for
Friday and I was sick and now we're
scheduled for Friday this time and uh
today happens to be Opex is because as
you guys are probably noticed we've done
these on fomc's they're all always
almost like really terrible days to
trade um so the downside of that is
um that we may not be able to see as
much cool stuff in terms of what there
is today um the upside is that we're not
taking up anybody's trading day not one
of my trading days and what I actually
did is I took a lot of
screenshots um of mostly from orderflow
from yesterday so if you guys are
interested if you go into the education
Channel there's like a whole
um uh I guess subchannel of Education
educational orderflow samples um and
those are going to be a lot of the ones
that I'm going through today um but
we're five minutes in so you know let's
get started actually and um I'm actually
going to start at the options profile
um and uh the reason for that yeah the
stream is going to be uploaded after the
reason that I'm going to start at the
options profile is because everything
that we're doing in the orderflow tabs
comes comes from here right so this is
all Zero D DTE options right which we're
using our classification on meaning that
um we're you know classifying buys
versus sells a lot of this will be old
news to everybody so I apologize to you
but
um we there's more you can read more
about it on the website but basically
these purple bars if they're to the
right it means that those are bought
puts purple bars to the left or sold
puts um orange bars to the right and
these are the default colors you can
change the colors and settings or bot
calls and orange B bars to the left are
sold calls so just very broad overview
you can see that today has has been you
know a very low volatility day
relatively speaking and so there's a ton
of sold puts underneath us and sold
calls above us on SPX which is very
typical right they're selling volatility
because volatility has been going down
it's a very profitable trade even if
sometimes you get caught
um and so another thing to mention when
we're looking at this is this is a
measure which is orthogonal to open
interest right so um at when the day
starts uh all of our like every single
contract for US starts at zero right so
there's no nothing on the books and then
as soon as you know the first
transaction comes in um we start
classifying and then uh that
classification it adds up over the
course of the day and then we end up
with something like this where you can
Point At You know these 4500 puts and
say oh wow okay you know they're long uh
approximately you know 5,400 of them
right um and so this is only for zero
DTE uh and eventually we're going to
actually start to incorporate more xeres
because the um orderflow classification
algorithm like it's quite robust so we
can apply it to more xeres but for right
now we're doing zero DTE because you
know that's where most of the options
volume
is okay cool so once you guys have that
in your head um the next thing to say is
that every single measure in order flow
is derived in some manner from this um
so let me actually hop over there
now all
right so I'm going to start here we're
going to start with these
three let me just get them scaled up a
little
bit and so what we're going to do just
to lay this out for everybody is we're
going to start by going through all the
different types of metrics so you guys
understand what each one of them are and
then we're going to dive into more
examples um and questions and stuff like
that um
so Dex order flow is potentially one of
the simplest metrics um because all it's
doing is it's saying um let me take an
options transaction that just took place
and then see what the Delta value of
that options transaction was um so for
instance if I'm looking right here and I
see
544.004 place that was net long
544.004 and then you go down to here
time based charts um I put all the
equations on here for everybody so for
instance Dex orderflow you can see that
it's bullish volume times Dex minus
bearish volume times Dex uh Dex in this
case is Delta exposure which is
literally just the Delta of the contract
multiplied by the number of contracts um
so and then and then up here we say you
know bullish volume is a long call or a
short put right because if you sell a
put that's essentially a long Delta if
you buy a call that's a long Delta
bearish volume is a short call and a
long put because if you sell a call
that's negative Delta and if you buy a
put that's also negative Delta um so we
are putting that all together into one
metric right here so that when you look
over and you see wow there was a really
big transaction here okay that means
that somebody just used options in order
to get net short whatever this is right
Deltas
um yeah so to simplify ryd yeah
absolutely so like if you basically if
it's a bar that's going down it means
that it's bearish order flow and if it's
a bar going up it means that it was a
buy it's bullish order flow right um and
this is all in terms of Delta
right um and then when you move down to
gex orderflow we're looking at something
really similar um except the difference
here is that we have this issue right
with Delta overflow which is that like
let's say that there's a big transaction
in in the money options right and those
in the money options are something like
an you know a 60 and 80 Delta something
like that a lot of times especially on
SPX and and I'm going to get into this a
little bit more later but depending on
the ticker uh a lot of times
transactions using in the money options
are actually used in tandem with other
products in order to exit a situation or
something like that um and so if you
really want to detect uh transactions
that have a lot of conviction behind
them you want to give more weight to
cases in which somebody is uh targeting
a uh let's say a 45 a 35 Delta option
something that's slightly out of the
money and especially cases in which
they're buying it because selling an
option is kind of going to make you
especially zero DT is going to make you
money most of the time um as that those
options Decay into the end of the day so
long as you're not completely wrong
about
Direction but when you buy an option you
really have to have conviction and
especially if you buy an out of the
money option you have to have conviction
and so what gex order FL flow does is
basically the same same thing as Dex
order flow except that in this
particular case we're multiplying um
that like the options transacted by
their gamma right so it means it's
basically going to tell us okay are
people looking for convexity right are
people looking for a crazy move in this
direction or that direction so um I'm
I'm just going to point to one just to
give give you an example like the way
that I think about reading these charts
um I usually will look at Dex order flow
gex order flow and con deity order flow
together and here's how it works right
so Dex order flow I'm going to look over
here and I'm going to say okay wow so
there's a lot of short Deltas that just
came in then I'm going to look and be
like okay well what was the
corresponding what was the corresponding
order right were was there any gamma
associated with that order and I'll look
down and there isn't much it's this tiny
bar right here right it's not
particularly big relative to the other
ones so that actually tells me that um
that
order isn't as substantial as I think
think it was right it's an order that
had a lot of Delta but this was likely
an in the money option that was
transacted right um and then if I move a
little further down and I go to
convexity order flow and this is where
things get a little bit more interesting
if convexity order flow is positive it
means that those options were bought if
convexity order flow is negative it
means that those options were sold so me
personally I'm more interested in
looking for options that get bought um
because that requires more conviction so
in a perfect case right like if I want
to find a signal right what would I do
well um I want the Delta to be in One
Direction right so like let's say that
actually let's maybe we can actually
look for a decent signal um let me see
here ah this is a good one actually this
is actually a pretty good short signal
right here so um the Delta was bearish
or it was negative right and then the
gamma was also about the same size as
the Delta and it was also significantly
negative and then if you go down you can
see
that uh let's see actually here yeah the
convexity I'm pretty sure I'm in the
same spot yes 32 uh 32 yeah perfect and
the convexity was positive so what this
tells me is that they bought an out
ofthe money put option um because
convexity is positive meaning it was a
bought option uh Dex is negative right
which means that um they shorted the
market and gex is also negative and of a
corresponding size meaning that they
purchased a convex option right so all
of a sudden all these three things line
up and I'm like okay cool I know that a
big transaction happen happened here
that was overall short the market right
um and so you can start to play with
this a little bit right um but it does
require a little bit that's why like the
order flow tab right is is a little bit
more advanced because it requires an
understanding of you know what all these
Greeks mean
um all
right all right so Rd is asking if it's
more important for Dex and gex to be the
same size size or if it's better if uh
it's a big size okay so um this like
just requires an understanding of like
the Delta options versus the gamma of
options right gamma is always the
highest at the money um and near the
money uh and Delta uh at least right for
an in the money call has a very high
Delta and an in the money put has a very
I guess low negative Delta meaning their
Delta is approach one so if you see a a
transaction with a with a lot a lot of
Delta um it it is telling telling you
hey you know this was a big transaction
but it could have been in the money
options that were used uh and I would
mostly disregard those so um I find that
you know Dex is a lot more sensitive and
so it's very nice to see like it helps
me a lot but I do in general prefer to
confirm with gex gex order flow to make
sure that the gamma of that option
especially like because gamma is going
to be the highest at the money right if
somebody buys an at the money option in
size that's a really big statement that
means a lot um because they're taking on
a lot of uh risk in doing so
all right dadbot is asking how you can
adjust the y axis oh um so if you guys
want to adjust any of these axes so for
instance uh you literally just Mouse
over and then you scroll on that axis so
for instance if you want to adjust the
strike price you scroll all right here
if you you can even adjust this guy
right you can zoom in and out on the
x-axis right yes s Trader exactly gex
validates Dex that's how I think about
it does that make s stabbot in terms of
the scrolling yeah yeah no it's all
designed the other cool thing about this
is if you double click on anything it'll
go back to the default
scrolling um so you can double click
always to return to I guess whatever the
default
is all right I'm going to take a beat
here before we continue because this is
actually I mean like it is a lot to take
in right so
um let me actually go into convexity
orderflow one more time right just to
clear that up a little bit so if you
guys scroll down here on the docs right
and you got to convexity order flow you
can see that um it's long order flow
times gex minus short order flowtimes
gex uh and the idea there is that um we
want to see um how much convexity was
purchased or sold right um so it's
actually an analog to gex's order flow
in a way except instead of sorting it by
bullish and bearish we're sorting it by
long versus short so for instance if the
market is selling off and you see a ton
of people people this is a pretty decent
example right here actually and let me
reload the page so that I can get these
lines to look how I want them to sorry
one one sec here all right
cool
uh
okay trying to see if there are good
examples like I said today is definitely
not the best day for this um but that's
fine so
long convexity looks like they purchased
calls there and
then this is actually probably the best
example that I can find right here to be
honest so if you look at at what
happened on this moment um and there's
still some bugs we got to fix with the
scrolling by the way but you know uh
we'll get there so in this particular
moment right we still had a lot more of
a selloff but as you can tell right like
there's a lot let me let me scroll this
up a little bit too um all of a sudden
we get these three three instances of
option selling come in one two three as
the Market's selling off right and in
general whenever volatility gets sold um
whenever options get sold into the
market they are providing liquidity and
the provision of
liquidity um it stifles volatility which
then leads the markets to come back up
so personally as primarily sort of an
options thinker SL Trader and by options
thinker I don't mean that I just mean
that I think in terms of options most of
the time um I really look at convexity
more than anything else because I want
to know um
whether uh whether there's being
liquidity provided to the market or
taken away from the market and then what
that does to my expectation of you know
the range that we're going to get
whether bottom has been put in or not
that sort of thing right um and so
convexity order flow all on its own can
be particularly useful to do just that
to see are people buying or selling
options right um
so but but the the most powerful usage
of all of these guys right the order
flow tools is all together uh cross
referencing between them because that's
a really good way to be able to identify
you know did something big happen number
one and then number two what happened
right were they um were they long or
short options were they were they
positive or negative Delta um and how
much convexity was involved in that
transaction so you can combine all these
three to do that
all right I'm going to take a second to
answer some questions and then we're
going to move on to the other three
metrics before we get to some
examples okay let's see
here um the uh feature request that just
came in would you mind putting that into
um
man um there's actually a feature yeah
thank you yeah all right so are these
tools available on a classic
subscription no no no these are this is
so there's three tiers of subscription
there's classic State and Order flow um
they're inclusive so State includes
classic order flow includes State and
classic but order flow is so to speak
the top tier um because in addition to
just providing you with the options
profile and like that that overflow
classification stuff this tells you when
something big is happening so like these
are really um you know this is sort of
the top tier these are like powerful
signals all right cool I think that's um
those are all the questions so far I'm
going to give you guys a second see if
anybody has one more I think someone's
typing
so I'll give that a second we're
actually making pretty good time
here and meanwhile I'll switch it over
to our net
measures
agregate okay
and net convexity oh oops my
B all right
SI liquidity pulling stacking okay
somebody's asking if I can elaborate
more on liquidity pulling stacking U my
interpretation of that question is that
they're asking
about um my comments with regards to uh
convexity and the way in which people
selling more options versus buying
options adds or subtracts liquidity from
the market um and this just has to do
with um sort of the basic
characteristics of of of options um so
if I sell a put right I'm entering into
an obligation to buy something at a
certain price by a certain time if I
sell a call I'm entering into an
obligation to sell something at a
certain price by a certain time so
there's are essentially limit orders
that you're that are coming right into
the market right um and so that's
essentially you know you're posting a
sort of collateral in order to buy or
sell at a certain price that's like a
liquidity provision basically to the
market um that's how i' explain that um
what is a liquidation break can you
detect that potentially ahead of time or
only after the fact so that is not
entirely related to the stuff that we're
discussing today um but really briefly a
liquidation break is when um price moves
to a level where all of a sudden there
is a lack of Supply or Demand right um
and so you can get that sort of a
squeeze right so normally we're used to
very liquid markets especially in the US
uh if you trade some like illiquid
equities okay like maybe not so much but
in the US the idea is well you know
prices move more or less smoothly they
move faster or slower but in general
there's always a buyer and a seller
there to adopt the next price at like an
increment of a cent a liquid ation break
is basically where all of a sudden
there's nobody there and so then prices
can just drop or they can they can Tech
technically also rise like crazy the
dropping is much more common um but yeah
that's not entirely related to the tools
that we um have developed here okay I
think that's enough
questions let's move on to the next
one okay so aggregate decks and actually
in order to explain aggregate decks I'm
going to pull up decks order flow here
okay
so um I think there is another sort of
competing uh service which I won't name
on this call that has something similar
to aggregate decks except um obviously I
prefer
ours but the idea behind aggregate decks
is um what would happen if over the
course of the
day you add up all of these bars that's
it that's really that it that's really
it we even have this little combined
metrics thing that Jasper just added
recently um although the scaling is
still we're still working on the scaling
but um the idea is right so every time
somebody it's it's just a measure of net
buying versus selling right so if it's
if it's going down it means that over
the course of the day more options have
been trans or more transactions have
occurred which have been short sorry
negative Delta right there's been more
selling than buying um using options um
and uh if it's positive and maybe I can
hop over to something else that might be
positive I doubt spy's positive
um oh it is okay that makes more sense
actually because today if we're up
usually like if we're up then one of spy
or SPX should be positive in aggregate
decks um but yeah it's literally just
taking up all the bars from the day in
order flow index order flow and adding
them um so the way that the way that
I'll use it basically is kind of as a as
a Divergence indicator typically um but
it depends and we're going to get to
this it depends on which ticker you're
looking at um uh and and and that's
actually quite
important um yeah I don't I don't know
how much more I can say about like what
it is that aggregate Dex is is that
clear do people have questions about
that uh I'm gonna Circle back to SPX or
spy actually because it's a really
interesting question and I think it's
very revealing of um a lot of the
Dynamics that that that that are at
least underway lately with ZT
options um
but yeah if you guys have more questions
about the way that aggregate dexs uh
it's literally just cumulative Dex order
flow that's it okay uh let's move on to
the next
guy uh and this can be a point of
confusion but net
gex uh the relationship between net gex
and gex Border flow is not the same as
the relationship between Aggregate deex
and Dex orderflow the reason for that is
because net gex is doing something
complet completely different so with net
gex uh what we're doing is or the main
question we want to answer is if the
market were to squeeze which way would
it squeeze right it's it's really that
simple um and so if net gex is positive
it means that if the market were to
squeeze it's more likely to squeeze to
the upside the reason for that is as
follows if you go into State and you
look at this all net gex is doing is
it's taking the gamma exposure of of the
calls um minus the gamma exposure of the
puts and so it's basically just telling
us do we have more GMA juice to the
upside or to the
downside um and this is using our
classified order flow so essentially
what happens is options profile
classifies a ton of stuff right then
that gets put into
this uh and then we do the call gex
minus the put gex and then that turns
into an orderflow
metric um which tells us where there is
more convexity so which side of the
market is more likely or or would get
squeezed if the market were to get
squeezed um and the reason that that's
different is because aggregate Dex
obviously is adding over the course of
the day its cumulative order flow but
net gex is taking the current state of
the options chain as we've classified it
and comparing the uh call gamma versus
the put
gamma all
right so um I'm going to move on to the
last one uh and the reason that that uh
here let's go we're going to do get rid
of this guy and then we're going to
compare net
convexity and convexity Order boom all
right
cool all right awesome okay so met
convexity is actually one of my favorite
metrics um and you guys have probably
seen me on the Twitter on Twitter maybe
talking about it as our version of the
vix um actually let me switch back to
SPX because that's what I'm more used to
looking
at okay sick
so
um here's why it's kind of like our
version of the
vix when we're doing net convexity is
very similar to net gex um except that
instead of comparing the state of the
chain in terms of call versus put gamma
we're
comparing um long versus short right so
basically imagine that we're here in
options profile and we have this many
options that are classified over here as
buys and all these options that are
classified as sells on this side right
we're taking the gamma of the bot
options and um subtracting the gamma of
the sold
options
and that's how we get to net gex
um
so the reason that that acts a little
bit like a vix is because it tells us
how much liquidity is coming into the
market from the option side right um and
so uh for instance like here I can say
that there's more like sold gamma so
more sold options in terms of their gex
than bought options and then when we get
up to here I can say okay there's more
bought options and sold options and so
forth um and so that's why right like
net convexity and net gex are analogs
right because they're both looking at
the state of the chain except net gex is
looking at the state of the chain in
terms of gamma as right like call gex
minus put gex and net convexity is
looking at the state of the chain in
terms of long versus short options um
bot options versus sold options um and
it's doing you know bought bought gamma
minus sold gamma
um so yeah that's actually all six of
the metrics I think yeah we've done all
of those which is great because that's
half hour so that that's perfect um so
somebody just asked a question I'm going
to do a couple more questions now um a
question related to options is there any
range hours where the options lose value
due to
Theta um options are always losing value
due to Theta so long as you're long an
option and if it's not in the money so
any out of the money long option that
you own is going to be losing value due
to Theta the there is a curve right
which is going to tell you how much
value you're going to lose due to Theta
um for any given point in time uh you
can just look at the Theta of the
particular option to get a sense for
that um and yeah with zero DTE like
after 2m it gets really really
bad uh negative convexity so somebody's
asking they ask a negative convexity
order flow does that mean that shorts
are entering the market in the docs it
says negative convexity is less Vol
expected um no so negative convexity has
nothing to do with shorts entering the
market um I'm not entirely sure what you
mean by shorts right because with option
like options are more complex than just
short or long um because you have you
have those four characteristics right
you have short long call and put right
so when you say short I don't know if
you mean short options or I don't know
if you mean negative Delta which is the
way that short is typically used when
referring to equities or stocks or
things like that um so when um when
convexity
um when net convexity is negative it
means that there is more short options
than long options in terms of their
gamma so yes that means that we're
expecting less
volatility um so when you see convexity
order flow go negative like right here
it means somebody just sold a ton of
options in this particular case in
retrospect I can see okay that was a
local top um they probably had entered
long and then they sold out of those
long options around here but then you
see after this enters we get a long
period of consolidation right here
because you know some like there was all
of a sudden you know um a lot of options
that basically uh how would I put it
they left the chat
right all right what is the pragmatic
use of this indicator when trading SPX I
mean that so we're going to get into
that um after going through all the
different
metrics all right
um yeah yeah that's that's pretty close
to right sain yeah um it's it's not a
perfect analog but like it's pretty
close uh suin basically said that when
net convexity net convexity has a
similar Behavior to uh the vix falling
meaning that either volatility gets
stifled or the index has a tendency to
move up up which is
accurate um Freddy's asking for most
directional trades which combination of
those tools uh would you think gives the
best
view so I think it really depends on
what you mean by a directional trade so
for me like I'm mainly a scalper um and
I don't necessarily use these for my
scalp entries um what I do what I do
like to do actually is I like to keep
net convexity up and I like to keep
aggregate decks up um and the reason for
that is because I want to get sort of a
sense for the generally what the uh what
the market is is or I guess what the
options Market is doing I kind of use it
as a way to gauge options Market
sentiment right um so for instance right
now I can see that net convexity spiking
a ton right um and so actually let me
check on the um and where are we we're
close to 230 which actually makes sense
so I mean I would anticipate that we're
going to break out of this range soon
basically um so I would be a little
careful for instance if I were selling
options in this environment because
nobody else is selling options which is
a little bit scary um and then with
aggregate decks I can tell that it's
climbing so it's been climbing right
it's finally started to climb on SPX so
I would favor a move to the upside for
instance so I kind of use that just to
get a general bias personally um but I
also know a lot of people that I I do
also like the orderflow ones but mainly
I use them in order to exit trades so
for instance if I see something crazy
come in I'll be like okay something's
going on you know maybe I should be a
little careful here but I'm going to get
more into that in a bit when we go into
SPX versus spy and then different
tickers and stuff like
that okay um o is asking have you
considered waiting the volume of es
Futures against the Deltas of the SPX
options traded to attempt to cancel out
immediate Hedges
or uh directional
Hedges
um yes I've considered it also it's
hard but it's not completely off the
table it's just hard um although I guess
if the time stamps are identical it's
it's kind of hard because like a lot of
times there's a little bit of a lag
right it's like um there was actually a
pretty cool instance today where um I
saw short a short come in in with Dex
orderflow gex orderflow and uh on
footprint on ES and it was around 4,000
lots and they all came in at once it was
pretty
cool
yeah no ratio is not a bad idea I think
we probably could do some
ratio um all right um since we've kind
of gone over those let's go into the
examples because I think the examples
will be a little more helpful and so
what I've done actually here is I put
together these like tab groups um so
these guys are from November 15th
um and let me see actually let's start
yeah let's start with with spy
right um so
uh this is two days ago right uh and
there's a couple of different
transactions that I want to point out um
one of the really big transactions or
the thing that stands out the most to me
is this guy right here um hopefully you
guys can see where my mouse is or this
guy right here or this guy right here um
uh this is a case where we can see that
convexity order flow is negative meaning
that those were sold options and then
there is a simultaneous uh Spike of
bullish decks and bearish decks and
bullish de and bearish decks basically
what happened here was um somebody sold
a massive
straddle um whenever you see something
like this it means that that that's a
big transition point so if we're running
up it means we're going to transition
start to go down um and this has to do a
little bit with the way in which people
trade spy in SPX um which is they're
trading volatility a little bit more
than they're trading directionally um so
I actually look for these spikes in both
directions here to give me a a solid
indication of what's uh of what's likely
a pretty big transition
Point um I think that's the only reason
I really wanted that one
um there's like you this is actually a
pretty decent example over here right
where we get another one of those and
then that's what stifles this down move
um so like there are good ways to find
uh pivots and transitions like a lot of
times if I wish I could zoom in here
because what you can see is that um
right
sometimes like a lot of times the moves
that are associated with these things
are happening it's like four points or
something like that right it's like a
relatively small fluctuation but it's
very nicely tuned up um and like if you
get right if you get onto these the nice
thing about it and we still have to fix
a little bit of that scaling but the
nice thing about it is like you can
actually start to see for instance like
okay this was a short right here on SPX
and and then price moved down a little
bit right and then there was a short on
SPX right here boom price moved down a
little bit right there was a short here
it moved down just a little bit and then
it rent right back up so it's not like a
um flag the straddles yeah that's a good
idea we could flag the straddles the
straddles are pretty
cool so if a short massive straddle is
sold it just means that price is about
to Pivot so we're going to switch
Direction I don't know whether we're
going up or down or whatever also if a
straddle is bought it means that price
is going to switch Direction basically
anytime you see a big straddle on SPX or
spy it means that we're going to switch
Direction um and uh you guys can ask a
if you want to know why because uh he
has a he has a pretty good handle on
that um and I'm going to continue
explaining these um okay so as you guys
all know today is
Opex o just typed in that he's leaving
um okay anyway uh as you guys know
today's Opex which means that you know a
lot of these things are very messy
because uh for those of you who don't
know Opex is the day where options the
the monthly options which are the most
uh voluminous ones right there's an
expiry they get moved rotated out to the
next month so there's a lot of
transactions coming through there's a
lot of volume there's a ton of stuff
going on so it's very very noisy um
which is why I have these screenshots
from the 15th but this is a very typical
case of um net convexity where like I'm
saying we're selling off at the
beginning of the day on SPX but net
convexity is also dropping meaning that
they're selling options and selling puts
most likely um and then as net convexity
drops boom we get a squeeze that makes a
lot of sense um because liquidity is
being provided to the market now as soon
as net convexity stops dropping over
here um is like it's actually only
halfway into the squeeze right The
Squeeze continues a bit more um but then
it gets completely stifled and when that
convexity stops starts running back up
is when oh we don't go any higher right
this is just staying around here it's
just staying around here it comes back
up and then like we sell off and then
this is also a very nice example right
here where we sold off but net convexity
actually came down into it meaning that
there were options being sold and so
price started to run back up um but then
that convexity came up and so then we
sold off again so it's like this is just
a very powerful way to see liquidity
entering or leaving the market by way of
options which is why I talk about it a
little bit like a
um and so this for for like let's say
that I'm in a a Futures position or
something like that um like if I see
that convexity is dropping and I'm long
um that'll give me more confidence to
stay in the position regardless of
what's happening for instance um so
that's you know that's
uh uh one way to use that I think I
already went through these guys okay
yeah awesome so that means that we're
done with this tab group and we can move
on to the next one all right um it's
time to talk a little bit about the
difference between between spy and SPX
which people were asking about earlier
um SPX usually gets traded um because
obviously the notional contracts is much
more significant it'll get traded by
um Traders with much more capital and
more elaborate strategies let's say so I
look at SPX more like a volatility
product um and honestly I could host a
whole live stream stream just on how to
read SPX because um it's not so much
about where it's going it's about what
the ranges are whether that range is
expanding or Contracting etc etc so if
you're primarily a directional Trader
and you don't want to think in terms of
volatility and options I would suggest
that you stick to spy or QQQ those are
going to be much much clearer in terms
of directional moves getting forecasted
and you won't see things like this all
of a sudden you're like oh wow okay and
and granted today's Opex right but here
you're looking at you're like well they
just bought why did it go down
ah well it's because a lot of times
they're contravening Futures positions
in SPX which are doing something else um
so it gets a little more complicated to
read and I would favor on SPX the
volatility based metrics like net
convexity over these bullish bearish
indicators if we move over to spy um all
of a sudden I have a bit more confidence
not all the way but more confidence in
terms of using so for every ticker right
if you see a big order come through a
orders coming through that means like
it's likely to be a transition Point
something's happening um for spy I'm
more likely to buy into the direction of
that order flow um and even more so for
the equities which we're going to get
into in a little
bit um but even for spy I'm I'm more
interested in for instance looking at
like I like aggregate decks for spy and
SPX um and net convexity to be
honest visualiz to support is going down
the past 30 minutes um
so I don't know I haven't been looking
I've been doing this live stream and
then the other thing is uh as I said you
know today's Opex so there's uh there
are a there's a ton of transactions
happening on many expirations besides
zero DTE which are very likely to be
controlling price today in addition to
all these things so um yeah that's a
good way to put it o too yeah normal DEC
I mean if if we were looking at them you
know the options profile I would
honestly for a day like today I'd look
more at the options profile to see um
and explain what's what's going on with
that and there is stuff going on there
today to explain the down move over the
past 30 minutes because I have it up on
another screen over here but um it
doesn't necessarily make sense to go
into right
now all right let's go into some more
examples um and like I said before right
like these examples are available in the
education and Order flow samples so you
guys can look through them
yourselves
um all right so like I said the equity
it makes a lot more like Dex order flow
in the equities makes a lot more sense
to me
typically um and so I just wanted to
point out a couple of different things
right you know right here we get a buy
run up get a sell right there run down
uh here this sell coincides directly
somebody probably they were accumulating
at the bottom here and then they sold
right when we hit here um and then and
then that stifles price movement right
and we just have this like retracement
here um similarly here right like you
get a massive cell and that triggers a
bit more of a sell again these are small
movements like this is designed for
intraday trading primarily um eventually
maybe we'll move on to more than
intraday trading but like that's really
what this is about here also we get two
massive buys next to each other um and
then that kind of gives us the action
for the close uh those are things I like
to see right like if I get multiple
transactions that come in um here is one
of those Strat that we talked about
where it's like bullish and bearish at
the same time boom marks an inflection
point um much cleaner like it's always
surprising to me I don't trade equities
but when I look over at the equities
they're typically much much
cleaner um here's the same uh yeah it's
also apple on the 16th and you can see
okay this was a big order because it was
Dex and gex um no convexity
paradoxically um which would mean that
um it was both long and short options
that were used so it was a synthetic um
but that's I guess that's a little bit
more elaborate
um yeah okay cool Apple's
done all right let's move on to
Tesla um this is aggregate decks on
Tesla right um so you can see for
instance this is my favorite moment of
this day right right here so all of a
sudden we're consolidating everybody
thinks ah you know maybe the downside is
over and then bam you just get a
massive uh drop in aggregate decks
meaning somebody just sold or or got
short via options and boom you get
continued downside um that's what this
thing is really really good at when all
of a sudden everything seems like it's
stable and then you get a big move in
the options market and then all of a
sudden you're like okay I think I know
what's you know what's coming right and
you're able to get position for it too
um so
yeah uh let me move on to the next one I
think that's why I had that one up these
are all from the same day by the way
like I'm just you know grabbing together
a lot of examples uh here's the same
example but in on Dex orderflow right
where um Tesla this is uh November 16th
so it was yesterday
Tesla um here here's the same thing that
happened right Dex order flow did this
and then if you look over and you look
at aggregate deck it did that so you can
tell that the scale of that transaction
that was huge right just like boom
relative to what was going on during the
rest of the day um and here you can do
that comparison that I was talking about
where you're like okay Dex order flow
Okay negative then you look at gex order
flow you're like okay that was a lot of
gex and then boom so I can tell actually
these were sold calls because it was a
negative convexity orderflow transaction
um so they sold a ton of calls right
there
um all right I don't know if there was
anything else that I wanted to look for
on this guy that was the the main one so
actually we can move on which is great
making great progress
here uh all right why did I have this
guy
here
oh yeah um so I think the reason I
pulled this up is because what I wanted
to say is right just because like price
does not necessarily need to follow
aggregate decks right I get deex tells
us what people are doing so in this
particular case I'd say that um I don't
know if I
have okay yeah yeah yeah okay so as
Amazon was pumping off the open um uh I
think probably it was calls getting
monetized here and then for the rest of
the day we do absolutely nothing right
um so for instance like if you're if
you're long Amazon and it's squeezing I
wouldn't necessarily say okay like
aggregate decks is going to
um is going to tell me exactly where
this is going to go but it is going to
tell you that um in general the options
Market is not participating in this move
so um this squeeze is not going to last
for very long um which is exactly what
happened it stabilized for the entire
rest of the day
right um I'll keep that open because it
seems like somebody's typing a question
but this is the other thing I wanted to
point out look at this order flow that
comes in right at the open on Amazon
um
so this to
me uh was the precursor to this giant
squeeze and then everything got there
wasn't necessarily yeah I know I'm
jealous of equities too right like
they're so much easier to read it's kind
of insane um there wasn't necessarily a
ton of Delta to that transaction but
there was a ton of gamma um so and then
as over the course of the rally they
were monetizing it so again like it's
useful to see these things in tandem
because then you can really get a sense
for what's actually going on um and so
this was right this was the initial
order boom they bought and then starts
to Rally monetize monetize monetize
monetize and then the movement is
stifled for the rest of the day because
we don't if we look over here right we
don't actually
get uh much more much more juice um all
right boom
boom oh um this was another one actually
this is literally the same day this is
all the same day on Amazon right but
what I liked about this one was um you
can see very clearly on net
gex oh like we're topping out same as
with aggregate decks right it's like
okay we rallied boom we're topping out
and it the signal comes before it
actually tops out um so this basically
means that um there wasn't much call gex
like they were monetizing those calls
there wasn't much call gex left in the
tank to continue this
squeeze all right all right that's
Amazon
oh I like this one okay here's for those
of you who are jealous of equities you
know here's here's more of a reason to
be jealous
um oh man I need I need a
break
um trying to think well I mean this is
kind of the same as that Tesla example
right where we just get a huge
transaction here and then it just leads
us this sell off
um
uh they don't necessarily always play
out right because we got potentially a
huge transaction here but the problem is
that when this huge transaction came in
and this is something to think about we
were already selling off right so if
we're already selling off and people are
selling
Deltas um that doesn't necessarily tell
me very much but if we're holding steady
and then I get a massive transaction of
people getting short that tells me
something right
okay um similar situation here right
we're Rising we're Rising we're Rising
Nvidia huge transaction uh this is the
this is also the 16th how was that oh I
guess the one I just did was the 15th U
massive transaction that tells me okay I
should probably get out um similarly
when we're consolidating here and then
all of a sudden aggregate deck spikes
you're like oh maybe I should get long
right and as soon as as long as agur
deck continues to move up it's it's
pretty good justification to get long so
this is like a beautiful case in which
you had a perfectly perfect little entry
right here perfect exit right there all
using aggregate decks you don't have to
think about too much um which is why
equities are a little
easier uh this is the same thing but
it's just the orderflow version of it so
you guys can see that right like this is
where uh that big it's a again it's a
double transaction those are always the
best when you see them hit the tape
twice there are two bars here boom boom
um get another one here and then you get
three transactions exiting right
here um um so that's that's pretty
useful uh I don't think we need to go
through this basically the same
thing
um yeah it's just Nidia is just really
clean right like you just get this like
massive cell Cascade boom um this
obviously not so
clean um so I think in terms of
selecting the orderflow filter that's a
really good question the way that the
Filter Works is that it's basically
taking um the biggest transaction that
day and the biggest transaction that day
is being set to
um to 100% um and
then um here let me hop back over here
and let's switch to something like
Nvidia let's make this
big all right cool
so the biggest transaction of the day is
here
right so if I set it to 100 only that
transaction will be there um it's always
a relative measure uh right like
relative to the other stuff that's
happened that day um and so you can see
that it's actually kind of logarithmic
right like the biggest transaction is
often multiple times larger than the
next biggest transaction or I guess what
is that like Paro distribution I I I
forget whatever but the the point is
that um so I usually will keep it set
like somewhere around here it depends on
like my trading frequency right it's
like what am I looking for um how many
trades am I looking to make a day do I
only want to get an alert so to speak
when something really big is happening
or do I want um and then this will do it
it'll automatically make it relative to
the biggest transaction that day for you
um which is kind of I don't know I think
it's kind of nice um I'm sure that like
historical volume you know I know people
like volume leaders do do a completely
different sort of thing but again like
these things are mostly designed for
intraday trading so um that's why we
built it like that
all
right yeah yeah I mean if yeah to try
and figure out what's noise versus what
is relevant I think the other thing
that's really helpful is like I would
always keep both of these guys up um
right so like this guy clear also man I
should have just used a video look at
this look at this buy which is like
confirmed on the on gex and then we get
this ramp up right here right um look at
this cell right here which is also
confirmed on gex and then we go move
right down um honestly if you only
looked at Dex and gex Order flow on
Nvidia you'd probably just like
um um yeah actually I would recommend
keeping the numbers the same between gex
andex um it's not you know it doesn't
matter like a th% because the the filter
is just going to control what shows up
it doesn't control the magnitude that
you see right but yeah I think it does
make sense sense right because this is
25% and 25% over here as well okay cool
let's move on let me see if I have
anything anything cool
left oh yeah
um uh we're we're almost an hour in so
I'm just G to uh run through these
really quickly and see if there's
anything in particular that I really
want to talk about I think this was for
the SPX and spy comparison primarily
that I had
this
M oh man I even have
more so I'd encourage all of you guys to
basically run through a lot of these if
you want and just to like try and
understand a little bit of the behavior
of course like really uh watching it in
real time is very very helpful and I
mean that's why the free trial is there
um yeah yeah you do get noise early in
the day um that's trading though the
open is uh all the different things that
I've looked at you know it's like it's
very very hard to get through the noise
of the
open um trying to think
[Music]
here I may want to go
into this was actually pretty beautiful
see sometimes decks works really well on
SPX
[Music]
um
as I'm going to reorient myself and you
guys feel free to throw questions in
there if you have
them
oh I know what this example was
about so this is actually a pretty nice
scenario because um if you have a case
like this where all of a sudden um Dex
orderflow starts
climbing on SPX right
um and net convexity is high that's
telling me two things at the same time
it's telling me people are buying Deltas
using the options market and in addition
to
that um they're buying it using long
options meaning that they're buying
calls right so all of a sudden I have a
setup I'm like oh wow people are
consistently buying calls net convexity
is high and aggregate deck is high uh so
it's not going to tell you all the
details but like I was saying in answer
to Freddy's question earlier like if I'm
trading Futures and I want to buy us I'm
like should I be Trading today from the
long side or the short side and I see
this happening I'm like okay if I trade
from the long side I'm to the long side
I'm much more likely to be able to catch
Runners all right
um oh I remember
um I remember actually uh Jazz took this
trade uh on the 16th at the end of the
day where net convexity started to dive
into the close and we started to ramp up
like that was a pretty nice especially
this guy right here boom really nice
level signal if you're just looking for
some points on
futures um
okay honestly guys I think we've mostly
gone through
everything
um
[Music]
yeah
yeah so I mean obviously like anything
it takes a lot of it takes screen time
and practice but you start to see things
um yeah I think I think that's good I
don't think I there's any other examples
that I necessarily want this one was
good on spy particularly because I
remember that right we were selling
off um and you know we just never broke
uh above zero on net convexity so I was
like we're not getting a big sell off
today that's the only thing I got from
this I was just looking at I was like
okay like they're just selling selling
selling options there's no fear here um
and yeah so that that type of thing can
be particularly useful
too all
right uh I'm GNA close all these guys
out
actually
so the the thing I want to mention in
closing um and I'm at exactly an hour so
that's that's perfect um is that um the
reason that at least this was the
thought process right like we put
together a tool we design something and
then people use it in ways we don't even
expect so I'm not going to say that this
is the way you should or need to use it
but the idea is when you're on SPX for
instance and you're looking at the
options profile there is a ton of
information here a ton and if you have
the orderflow tab not only does it give
you signals but it tells you this is
like your map right like this is where
this is this tells you where liquidity
is this tells you um like where your
stops should be where other people's
stops are all that stuff right it's kind
of like a massive like we call it
options profile because it's kind of
like a volume profile but the thing is
there's so much going on behind the
scenes that if you don't have something
like
orderflow you and I'm not saying you
need it you don't necessarily need it
but it can help you to identify when
something big is happening somewhere and
then if you use the parts of order flow
in tandem you can say okay for instance
like here I'm like okay somebody got
short Delta and it was gex and then I
personally need like I take the
convexity order flow and be like okay
and it was short it was a short option
it came through in other words somebody
sold calls here boom boom boom somebody
sold calls then I can move over back to
State and again hopefully you have these
on multiple screens um and you can be
like okay where did they sell calls and
then you can use the dots to figure it
out right and maybe that impacts your
trading in some way or another um and so
using all these things together it's
essentially a way to be able to monitor
exactly what's going on
um without missing anything um so yeah
that's the idea um yeah Simon I mean
yeah I don't I'm not saying like how
would I put it like
uh it's not for everybody uh if you know
if you get it if you like it if it makes
sense to you um uh maybe you try you see
some things you're like wow you know
this this this I caught something right
that I wouldn't have caught otherwise
and that was valuable to me then uh you
know that's great that's that's what
it's made for um to be honest me
personally because I mostly just trade
uh futures um and I'm very very used to
reading this latter uh I usually am on
options profile and then I will check
order flow for net convexity and
aggregate decks that's what I like to
do um but we have a lot of people that
use the um the order flow stuff uh eim
the Dots here tell you what the past
values were so for instance if you were
to have your mouse over here this will
tell you this is where it was five
minutes ago this is where it was 15
minutes ago and that's where it was 30
minutes ago um and that's a way to see
if strikes have been growing or
shrinking all right um here's what I
think I'm going to do because that was
the whole educational section here I'm
going to give you guys another five
minutes to ask questions um and then
after that I'm going to stop the
recording I'm going to wrap it up but
I'll hang out in case more questions
come up because I don't really have
anything to do for the next hour anyway
so um and we can uh maybe comment the
close like o was asking about
um yeah why not why not there's some
other things I want to pull up though if
we're going to do that because this is
not the only thing that I want to be
looking at
um oh yeah of course it gives Mouse like
expected range like I
mean this is you can also I mean you can
hop wherever you want right but
like you know major positive and major
negative are typically your guard rails
right so yeah this can be really useful
honestly so I use it for trading Futures
but um
I used to trade a lot of options and um
man I wish I were trading options using
this because it would tell me exactly
where to be positioned it's just that
the thing is like if you're used to
trading zero GTX or if you've done any
of it um the mental toll that it takes
it it just like demolishes you it's not
uh michig andolf was talking about this
it's it's it it may not be worth it you
know I don't know if any of you guys
trade zero DTE I would not advise but um
it's kind of like cocaine not
good gray hair essential yeah exactly
Deon yeah also sorry guys if this was
I'm I'm sure this was very dense you
know um but you know we got it all done
in an hour uh and uh you you got to be
willing to to get your hands a little
dirty I think if you want if you want
that edge a little bit I don't
know